i heard this interview with uh david
foster wallace on the internet
where it's uh it's a video of him and
there is like a a foreign sounding
reporter asking him questions i think
she's
there's an accent of some sort german i
think something like that and i don't
know it just painted a picture such a
human person we were talking about
listening
the interviewer if i may say
uh wasn't a very good one
in the beginning
so she
kind of walked in doing the usual
journalistic things of just kind of
generic questions and and just kind of
asking very basic questions but he
brought out something in her over time
and he was so sensitive and so sensitive
to her and also
sensitive to being
a thinking and acting human in this
world that's just painted such a
beautiful picture that people should go
definitely check out they made me really
sad that we don't get this kind of
picture
um of of other thinkers uh all of the
ones we've been talking about just that
almost this little accidental
view of this human being
i don't know there was a beautiful one
and i guess there's not many like that
even of uh him yeah yeah no i think he
was
more
than his
writing ability which was extraordinary
it developed a style that was i think
unlike you know anyone else's style and
it was his
sensitivity
to other people and to
sort of what he was there to pay
attention to
he wants in one of his um
essays i think it's the one called an
incredibly fun thing i'll never do again
you know that one about cruise ships i
think he describes himself as this sort
of roving eyeball that just sort of
walks around the
walks around the ship noticing things
and he's incredibly good at that
but i also do but i also worry
that that reflects something that you
find in ivan in in the brothers
karamazov
ivan i don't know if you remember this
part
when he's away at school as a young a
college as a young boy he makes money
by
going around town to where tragic events
have occurred someone just got run over
by a carriage or someone you know
something just happened
and
being the first one there
he always knows somehow where these
things are going to happen and writing
about it
giving this really good description
and then signing it eyewitness
and
it's as if
ivan's understanding of his life is that
he was supposed to be a witness
to it he was supposed to see others but
not get involved
he never is interested in trying to keep
the bad things from happening he just
wants to report on them when he sees
them
and i think that he's an incredibly
isolated person
character and it's his isolation
from others from the love of others and
his inability his desire not
to love others because that attaches him
to someone
that i think is really at the ground of
his
condition
and and i think that aim to be isolated
which many people have nowadays i mean
you see it in the underground man too
just sort of taking yourself out of the
world because
you don't want to have to take
responsibility for being involved with
others
i think that's a bad move and and i and
i do worry that maybe i mean i never
knew david foster wallace i have no
right to
to comment you know on on his life but
he portrays um himself in that one
episode as a person who who does that
and i think that's dangerous yeah
there's some sense in which being
sensitive to the world like i find
myself the the source of joy for me is
just being really sensitive to the world
to experience
there's some way
it's quite brilliant where you're saying
that
that could be isolating
it's like darwin's studying
uh a new kind of species on an island
you don't want to interfere with it you
find it so beautiful that you don't want
to interfere with this beauty
um
so there is some sense in which that
isolates you and then you find yourself
deeply alone
uh
away from the experiences that bring you
joy
yeah
and that could be destructive
it's um that's fascinating how that uh
that works and in his case
of course some of it is um
just chemical chemicals in his brain but
some of it is the
the the path
his uh philosophy of life let him
down
and that's the danger we need you too
and gazing into the abyss
uh that you can um
your job is a difficult one because uh
doing philosophy
changes you yeah
and
you may not
know how it changes you until you you're
changed and you look in the mirror
you